-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
We hope you're doing well.
And now, if you don't mind,
we're going to get to the news.
When asked yesterday about his
age as he runs for re-election,
President Biden said that it
doesn't register with him.
Okay. I know you're trying
to play it cool,
but you made it sound
like a symptom.
"My age, I never remember."
[ Laughter ]
That's right.
When asked about his age,
President Biden said,
"I took a hard look at it
before I decided to run.
And I feel good."
Listen, we don't care
how you feel now.
Did you see what eight years
did to Obama?
[ Laughter ]
If you get re-elected,
this is what you're going to
look like
by the end of 2028.
[ Laughter ]
President Biden greeted kids
today on the White House
South Lawn as part of
Take Your Child to Work Day.
Unfortunately,
it was a trap set up
by Congress
to arrest Hunter Biden.
Former president Trump's
new book, "Letters to Trump,"
went on sale this week
for $95 -- $95!
[ Laughter ]
Let me give you the gist
and save you the cash.
"Dear Mr. President,
for the last time,
the Grimace cannot attend
your inauguration.
We hope this will be
the final word on the matter.
Sincerely, McDonald's."
[ Laughter ]
A source recently told
"People" magazine that former
president Trump respects
and admires former
First Lady Melania Trump
and wants to make her happy.
But he plans to stay married
to her anyway.
[ Laughter ]
After being fired
from Fox News on Monday,
Tucker Carlson
posted a video last night
to Twitter and said,
"Where can you still find
Americans saying true things?"
Well, hell, you've already tried
Fox News and Twitter.
I'm out of ideas. I don't know.
Maybe Wall Street.
[ Laughter ]
A bipartisan group of senators
yesterday introduced
the Protecting Kids
on Social Media Act,
which would set the minimum
age to 13 for platforms
including Instagram,
Facebook and TikTok.
Wait, you're trying to keep kids
under 13 from using Facebook?
[ Laughter ]
What's next? You're not going
to let them wait in line
with you at the bank?
[ Laughter ]
Workers in Wales recently
misspelled the word "school"
while repainting
a section of road.
To be fair, this is how
you spell school in Welsh.
[ Laughter ]
A court in Germany
ruled yesterday
that the tenants of a building
do not qualify for reduced rent
because their landlords
sunbathe naked
in the courtyard.
Said the judge,
"Think of it this way --
free sundial."
[ Laughter ]
[ Light applause ]
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
I don't need your applause.
[ Laughter ]
But I stand by that joke.
And finally,
according to a new report,
trained dogs can help detect
coronavirus infections
in schools.
Cats can, too. They just won't.
[ Laughter ]
That was a monologue, everybody.
We're off.
We're off and running.